[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
July 18th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]
for parents sending children off to
college can be one of the largest
expenses they'll face Wall Street
Journal contributor Cheryl Whittaker
monk joins us to discuss common
Financial missteps some families and
students make
so Cheryl whenever we talk about
families and managing budgets it often
starts with a conversation about money
what should parents discuss with their
child before they head off to college
pretty much everything and I don't mean
to be flip in that respect but you
really really need to set clear
expectations for what their spending
will be college is a lot of money and I
just saw a study saying that a lot of
parents aren't expecting it to be as
much as it actually is food is a big
area for example let's say as a freshman
year on a three point meal plan a day
program it's very easy to say the food's
disgusting or I just feel like having
something else and then buying a pizza
every night and not only is that
probably not healthy for you but it's
also just it's a lot of extra money that
a family could be shelling out so costs
besides tuition and room and board and
food those expenses are usually well
known they might play a part in What
school a student selects but what other
expenses do students and families often
Overlook or underestimate transportation
is a big one even my own family we sort
of didn't really think about that my
daughter is going to be going to a
school out of state like every time she
comes home for Thanksgiving maybe other
holidays maybe just a visit during the
year so we're going to have to have a
conversation about expectations and say
it's expected that you're going to come
home at Thanksgiving and winter break
but you're not taking 10 unexpected
trips home during the year because it
could be multiple hundreds of dollars
each time she's doing that college kids
still buy books sometimes you can get
them online although you do have to be
careful of online scams because there
are unfortunately scammers out there who
prey on students but also sometimes that
you can get them used at the bookstore
even or share them with someone although
that's also sometimes a risky strategy
if the person isn't is diligent about
sharing is you are the other issue
computers so if someone was giving me an
example of they bought their daughter a
new computer and the computer broke or
was dropped or something like that so I
mean yes there's Insurance sometimes it
works sometimes it doesn't but you just
have to be careful of those other little
things
now if a student entering College
doesn't qualify for a credit card yet
and parents list their child on their
own credit card what should they keep in
mind so in this case what they're doing
is they're making them what's called an
authorized user so they'll get their own
plate and they can use it as they wish
the parent needs to be very clear with a
child what expectations are for spending
on that card
you don't want the child to just go off
and run up your bills completely because
you're responsible for that card this is
a good strategy if a child doesn't have
income to get a credit card on their own
which many 18 year olds will not even 19
and 20 year olds won't but you do have
to be careful because it the spending on
the card will affect the parents credit
as well as the student so it has an
impact on both
so my kids are authorized users at one
of our cards and what we do is I get an
email every time the card is used you
can do this with most cards I've set it
up for a very low threshold so I think
it's a penny so any time it's spent
whether it's money is spent online or
whether money is spent at a bodega or
anywhere I get an email so okay this
causes problems sometimes because my
husband always jokes that that he can't
ever spend anything without me knowing
but it's a really good tool not only for
monitoring your children's spending but
muttering for fraud well there are no
secrets in your house
nope not on this card
now let's assume for a moment that a
student's parents are paying for tuition
and room and board what steps do they
need to take to gain access to the
student's account to keep up with
balances so it's going to depend on the
school most times that there's an
authorization form or forms that the
student will have to fill out most times
it's online these days oftentimes that
they'll discuss is the orientation or
parents will start getting emails and
they'll say make sure you know this is
coming up make sure your student grants
you access and then you just have to go
through a multi-step process to get that
access also even though the parent is
paying for this they wouldn't
automatically have access to all these
numbers no because the college just
assume that because they're adults now
they're really in charge of their
finances and even though many parents do
pay for their education it's not an
automatic right to get access
now paying for tuition and room and
board those are expenses that can really
rack up over time and many families
might tap into a 401k to withdraw funds
to cover College costs and that's
allowed under the rules but why would
that be risky
so if you make cash withdrawals and 401K
loans if they're not paid back on time
that's going to add to the parents
taxable income and that could push them
into a higher tax bracket which no one
really wants to be in a higher tax
bracket it also increases what's known
as the expected family contribution and
that figure is used to calculate
financial aid you could be essentially
shooting yourself in the foot the other
issue is attacking retirement money
means that you might be giving up
investment gains on that money so there
are reasons not to do it that's Wall
Street Journal contributor Cheryl
Whitaker Monk and that's your money
briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]
thank you